I think 3d on ice is probably the only
way to see this film I mean it's
spectacular this truly demands that
experience because of how the media and
and beautifully textured and dimensional
the the film is visual feast for the
eyes it's probably worth seeing it twice
you know when the ancient one opens
strangest third eye I don't know if you
can take that whole entire journey in
one visual sitting it really is stunning
there's a lot of IMAX footage over an
hour of footage in it and I love the
fact that when you're watching a movie
in IMAX you can switch from the to 400
frame it's the IMAX Frank frame and the
audience never knows it but they feel it
they feel when that screen pops wide for
the bigger shots movie that I was very
thoughtful about wanting that in fact my
preferred thing is to have the impact of
it going why I'd use that for all the
major visual effects sequences for all
the big location footages in in Katmandu
the opening in London what you get by
sitting and watching it is almost
impossible to explain in Morse you don't
feel you're sitting in a theater you
feel as if you're in the film and that's
a rare experience I'm very philosophical
about IMAX actually because I love the
format and it's it's the difference
between watching the movie and being in
a movie and as a cinephile sinner who
loves cinema I look at the frame the way
I would look at the frame you know in a
in a painting but then IMAX becomes a
different kind of cinema altogether what
they've done with the visual effects in
this world is phenomenal it's another
level for cinema let alone the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but just film
full-stop to travel down strange
stronger men than you have but their way
IMAX 3d up close is the greatest thing
ever
because the the frame disappears and and
you literally are inside the movie and
it's not like any other kind of cinema
experience and and it's it's that not
every movie is suited for it but this
one certainly is these effects have an
effect on an audience which is
purposeful like a character but it's not
just fireworks it's really the tackle to
the storage and then to realize it on
that scale of account survivors it's
brilliant
I've spent so many years peering through
time
looking for you
you